Hundreds of miles south
of Gaza, turmoil in the Red Sea
not seen in decades
as Iran backed Houthi forces
step up attacks on ships
that they claim have ties to Israel.
This has led to a major disruption
in global shipping as companies
such as oil giant BP
reroute vessels
all the way around Africa
to avoid attacks.
CNN's Natasha Bertrand and Richard Quest
joining us now.
Natasha, remind us who the who these are
and how is the U.S.
responding to these attacks?
Well, Jake,
the Houthis are basically one
side of a civil war
that has been raging in Yemen
for the better part of a decade now.
They are a rebel group
that managed to seize
control of many parts of Yemen
beginning in 2014.
They now control
a large part of northern Yemen,
and they have been
fighting a separate war
against Saudi Arabia
over the last few years, a war
that has abated over the last year
because of a cease fire.
But they are also backed by Iran,
which of course, is Saudi Arabia's
arch nemesis in the region.
So a lot of different powers
at play here.
But what the US is doing at this point
to try to deter these ongoing missile
and drone attacks by the Houthis
on these
commercial vessels is to set up
an international coalition
of maritime forces
that will basically be bolstering
the security in the Red Sea
and when necessary,
escorting a lot
of these commercial vessels
so that they can transit safely
through the southern Red Sea and up
towards the Suez Canal, where, of course,
so much of international trade
and commerce passes
through on a daily basis.
Now, the U.S.
is saying that they are not necessarily
going to escort these ships
on a regular basis,
nor are the other countries in the area.
It's really just
an attempt to show
that the international community,
the international shipping
industry, that they are there
in case they need them,
and also to try
to show the Houthis
that they are prepared to respond
if they
do these additional
attacks in the future.
But of course,
that has not worked in the past.
Over the last few weeks, the U.S.
has responded to these missile
and drone attacks,
shooting down
several of the missiles
the Houthis have fired.
It has not deterred them today Jake.
Richard, what does this mean
for global trade
if ships have to reroute themselves
all the way around Africa?
Oh, it means about ten days, 15
days, two weeks round day
are eight and a half thousand miles
to go from Singapore up
through the Suez Canal to Rotterdam,
11,000 miles.
Only 12
if you're going to go around the Cape.
I spoke an hour ago
to the CEO of Hapag-Lloyd.
One of his ships
had already been hit
by one of these drones.
He said if it had been hit
somewhere else,
it would have been much worse
for the vessel.
It's going to be very difficult
to protect these ships
because there are so many of them.
You've got to shoot down all the drones
and it becomes a long,
costly, expensive affair.
And so that's the economic balance, Jake.
Do you send these ships around
which will create supply chain issues,
likely
raise the prices
and increase inconvenience, or
do you take the risk of the Suez
Canal route,
which frankly
no one seems to be prepared
to do at the moment, at the second?
I'm afraid to say
the Houthis have the upper hand.
And Natasha, we know that the U.S.
has responded
by launching strikes at weapons depots
in Syria and Iraq.
Our Pentagon officials are discussing
a more substantial response
to deter these attacks
by the Houthis to begin with.
Well, look,
the Pentagon will always tell you
that nothing is off the table
in terms of a response.
However, the U.S.
has been extremely reluctant to bomb
the Houthies directly
and their infrastructure
also because there are several
political sensitivities at play as well.
As I mentioned earlier, Saudi Arabia
and the Houthis,
they reached a very fragile truce
just last year.
And the U.S.
played a very important role
in that truce.
And so the US does not
necessarily want to see
a new conflict
reopened in Yemen
against the Houthis, as well as,
of course, many Arab nations.
They don't necessarily
want to see these conflict, these
this conflict escalate either.
And so the US does not necessarily
want to open a new front here.
But many critics are pointing out
that there may need
to be
some additional kinetic action
in order to deter
their attacks in the future
because they're just not letting up
with ballistic missiles,
anti-ship missiles
and increasingly sophisticated equipment.